You've now gotten everything you need to
get started with building Android apps
that use Google Services.
The API's that you've installed, give
you access to all of this functionality.
And they give it to you
in a consistent way.
Remember that Google API client that
you saw for accessing your location?
It's the same object, and very similar
code to what you'd use to access Google+
or Maps or Wallet or Drive.
You can learn these in
any order you like.
But the most important thing is
to get started and to get coding.
So, you'll see just how easily you
can harness all this goodness.
You should go and
take the location module first,
because many of the concepts you'll
need for the others are covered there.
Let's go.